على كل المزيد من التفاصيل ينضم الينا من
القاهره الناقد الفني طارق الشناوي سيد
طارق اهلا بك معنا من جديد في مساء
العربيه اليوم نتحدث عن محمد رمضان اهلا
اهلا بك يعني محمد رمضان سعيد بالاحتفالات
ببراءه العمده وغرد يقول هذه ميزه الجمهور
لما يحبك هل هو بالفعل حب محمد رمضان
الممثل ام حب
لا طبعا كاريزمه محمد رمضان كممثل موجوده
في اغلب اعماله مؤكد لكن لما بتتعمل شخصيه
متركبه صح
وبتراعي الاحساس الشعبي وده اللي عمله
محمد سامي ككاتب ومخرج للمسلسل فبتلاقي رد
فعل ضخم انا متذكر انه قبل كده حتى في
الاسطوره كان في كل لحظه بيحصل حاجه في
المسلسل الناس بتنفعل بها يعني اذا اتقبض
عليه يحزنه اذا افرج عنه مش المره الاولى
لرمضان اللي يحذر بهذا الكم من الحب
من التماهي يعني ناس
بتبص دلوقتي على شخصيه الدراميه واكلناها
واقعه يعني يخترق المسلسل وبالذات بطل
مسلسل محمد رمضان الشاشه الى الشارع فاصبح
جزء من الشارع
بحريصين على ان هو
ينجو من اي عقاب حريصين على انه يحقق
طموحاته انه يلاقي ابنه وهكذا فهي الحقيقه
حاله ما اقدرش اقول بس الدراما لكن ايضا
تركيبه الممثل يعني وده لنا مثلا في
الماضي كان فريد شوقي مره في احد الافلام
حد صفعوا على قفاه فالناس كسرت السينما
فيهم صاحب السينما كسر السينما اللي هو
هيدفع حقها بعد كده انه هيصلح الكراسي
وكده لكن لم يرضوا انه فريد يتضرب ايضا
جعفر او محمد رمضان هو ماشي في نفس
الاتجاه اللي هو فكره النجم الجماهيري
اللي الجمهور يتوحد عليه ويصدقوا في كل
حاجه هنا ملناش علاقه ببعض مشاكل متعلقه
بالكتابه الدراميه ممكن في مشاكل دراميه
لكن يجب ان نحترم الزائقه الشعبيه يعني لا
نتعالى على الجمهور في اعمال اتكلمت كتير
جدا ربنا مردود يا استاذ طارق يعني
المتعاطف وغدر وخيانه هل هذه وصفه الخلطه
الشعبيه انصح التعبير
[موسيقى]
لا ما تكفيش الوصفه لازم لها مقادير ممكن
لو زياده المقادير في حته وقلت في حته لا
تحقق نفس النجاح لكن اهم من الخلطه النجم
يعني لو شيلت محمد رمضان من جعفر العمده
وجبتي نجم اخر تاكدي انه النتيجه هتنزل
على الاقل 50% يعني فهي ايضا مرتبطه بمدى
جاذبيه النجم وناس مصدقاه في النغمه
الشعبيه دي مش كل حد الناس تصدقه في اعمال
دراميه رمضان بالذات لما بيلعب في السكه
دي مع نفس الكاتب والمخرج محمد سامي ويمكن
ده ثالث لقاء بينهم ويحقق قدر النجاح كبير
ويصل ان الناس بتحب تتفرج على المسلسل
اللي بتحبه في المقاهي عشان يبقى انفعال
جماعي مش فردي وكانه فيلم مش حلقه
تليفزيون يعني عايز اقول فيه حاجات كثيره
بنقدر نعرف منها مدى النجاح الشعبي الحقوا
هذا انا رايي انه بكل عيوب وربما بسبب كل
عيوب يعني احيانا العيب بيبقى ميزه طب
عايز اقول بكل عيوب وبسبب هذه العيوب اللي
موجوده
في جعفر الناس حبيته يقول كل الناس طبعا
قطاع عريض من الجمهور المستهدف توحد حول
الشاشه وتوحد ايضا حول شخصيه فكره ان
يتزوج من اربعه برضه جزء مهم طب هذا
بالنسبه للمسلسل التفاعل الكبير اللي
شفناه على مواقع التواصل مع المسلسل هل
يثبت يثبت نجاح المسلسل فنيا ام يثبت فقط
انه اكثر متابعه
[موسيقى]
بصي انا ما اقدرش انكر انه انه شعبيا
المسلسل يعني يحظى بلقب الاكثر وهنا مش
محتاج لارقام لان في في تفاصيل كثيره في
الشارع بتؤكد على التوحد حول هذا العمل
الفني
انما هل هل بقياس الجماهيري هو بالظبط
المقياس العلمي الفني النقدي بقول لا ولكن
على الناقد كمان ان هو يطل بنظره اخرى
عندما يجد ان هناك مردود شعبي لعمل فني له
تحفظات عليه يجب ان يطل بعين ثانيه ليرى
لماذا اقبل الناس بالرغم كثير من الهنات
الدراميه موجوده في تكوين الشخصيات في
حاجات بتخاسم المنطق في حاجات ايضا بتحتاج
لتفسير قانوني ما هواش مظبوط منضبط يعني
بالضبط ولكن في النهايه دي ذائقه شعبيه
علينا ان احنا نحترمها ممكن قطعا ان احنا
نحللها لكن سبحانه وتعالى عليها قال انا
ملاحظه من اول ما بدا المسلسل هناك بعض
الاقلام تتعالى على الفن الشعبي لا الفن
الشعبي طول عمره له جماهريته له ناسو ويجب
الا نتعالى محمد عبد الوهاب كان بيسمع
احمد عدويه بالمناسبه يعني راح لكازين
الليل عند شريفه فاضل عشان يسمع احمد
عدويه
وعبد الحليم حافظ غنى السح الدح انبوبه مع
احمد عدويه دي كلها حقائق موجوده ونجيب
محفوظ اكتر اثنى على احمد عدويه ايضا عايز
اقول هنا المردود فكره انه الفن الشعبي
الغنائي وايضا الدرامي كوجه اخر للفن
الشعبي الغنائي موجود عند محمد رمضان انت
دايما كلامك مشوق يا استاذ طارق ودرر فعلا
نحن بنقعد نستمتع ونحن نسمع لك يا استاذ
شكرا جزيلا لك الناقد الفني طارق شكرا من
القاهره شكرا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات